foreign
[Music]
the dominant cause is the glacial effect
from the last ice age that pushed down
the Mid-Continent and caused a bulge
along the Eastern Coastline and when the
ice melted that reversed everything so
the midcontinent's rising and the
Eastern Seaboard is sinking about one to
two millimeters a year that's the
primary signal we see that superposed on
that or other things we have different
kinds of soils across New York City
including artificial fill that can that
was put in to enhance some of the land
areas and that can sink just under its
own way because it's so poorly
Consolidated and if you build on that of
course that exacerbates it and of course
the the other contribution that we
looked into in this manuscript was the
the weight of the the buildings
themselves the force that they applied
to the ground and caused further
substance it's inevitable that crowns
going down the waters coming up at some
point those two levels will meet but I
just am not able to give you a date